freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher koch
es ist ein bisschen verrückt so der
zehnjährige max wird es wahrscheinlich
nicht sauer aber ich gehe in dem eco
geld hatte ich hoffe euch natürlich zum
frühstück ins french toast ein gesunder
smokie ich habe probiert so ein bisschen
das gleichgewicht zu finden ist ein
bisschen auf der gesunden wave na ja
genau ich will nimmt gerade bisschen
abführen mit filmrollen
ich sage nicht rasieren und so heute
vergessen wir das alles ja ich bin schon
sehr gespannt was denn max so zaubern
wird ja ich gebe mir große mühe macht
hier gerne gemütlich und zauberer messi
vor der erste regel bei french toast
brioche verwenden game changer ich habe
schon einmal freund schluss gemacht dass
es in dem video wirklich das macht es
einfach 1000 mal besser wenn er nach
trost benutzt wird auch gut aber rasch
1000 mal besser der fresh brauchen wir
und ich habe mir ein paar frische serie
geholt dann wird das ganze noch ganz im
sinne von tk mit nutella getoppt da
brauchen wir noch ein paar eier und ein
bisschen milch wird schon mal vom
staaten dazu machen noch ein kleines die
fertig den bereich ich glaube ich schon
mal vorbild der genau wer kann schon
fertig sind also wir stellen jetzt
zweierreihen sodann 100 milliliter milch
dazu ich möchte das jetzt nicht aber
ungefähr soviel nicht wundern wenn zum
hintergrund paar spiel geräusche gibt
der kleine leiter ist auch hier und hier
gerade portals glaube ich aber überhaupt
kein problem
nehmen wir mal so 3 und ich glaube da
ist soviel mäßig gekommen weil das alter
für das wird jetzt verkehrt so dass
jetzt eigentlich fertig da ziehen wir
gleich einmal das bremer spiel bevor wir
fangen anlagen in butter aber wir machen
mit dem smoothie weiter
ich bin ja alles wissen ex-frau sarah
ist auch eine köchin hat auch einen
kanal auf youtube wird auch mal
verlinken und in diesem mixa hier kann
man auf jeden fall ordentliches mutig
neue ich habe selbst nicht so krass ist
zu hause aber wir fangen mal an
mit ein wenig gefrorener mango die
machen das ohne groß abzumessen oder so
sondern seine augenmaß also verein damit
okay wir machen jetzt ein halb bananen
noch dazu in den mixer und ich habe das
sehr ernst genommen mit dem gesunden
ikone
guck mal hier wie spinat für den zügig
ein bisschen spinat dazu sehr gut ich
hoffe du sagst dass auch noch wenngleich
vergessen so dann brauchen wir noch ein
wenig frischer minze darin habe ich
schon häufiger gemacht ich habe die
reform ins bett will da jetzt noch
heftig zu passen
dann stehe ich noch ein bisschen
irgendwann brauchen gar nicht so super
viel verstehen einfach nochmal so diese
ecke und ihr kennt ihn treten im level
geht das ultra easy plan kommen noch ein
bisschen orangensaft dazu müssen wir das
durch oder ist der auch schon fertig ich
glaube er ist sogar ein bisschen
frisches obst das ist vielleicht einfach
dazu sagen werde ein bisschen banane
noch und ich habe hier meine
drachenfrucht geholt wenn es schön
aussieht mit ihrem kampf dann
entscheiden
ich habe jetzt mal hier die
drachenfrucht noch einfach echt hübsch
und dann kommen ja auch mit den fans
schloss
sodann habe ich jetzt hier eine große
fahne auf gesetzt da gebe ich ein wenig
butter hinein also dann wurde es in der
pfanne wird heißt packen das auf
mittlerer hitze dann gehe ich hier
einmal die french toast wie gesagt so
für ein paar sekunden in diese mischung
ein dass sie sich auch sorgen dann legen
wir hier einfach in die pfanne rein und
folge dir aus dass wir von beiden seiten
so richtig schön goldbraun werden so ich
guck mal da sind runter
wir können auf jeden fall noch nicht
hingehen wir noch ein bisschen mehr gas
wird so dann ist es auch schon soweit
wir sehen uns gleich ein angerichtet ist
dann wird über ein sehr bunter teller
wir wissen was gesundes damit der teller
ein bisschen voller aussehen habe ich
auch mal dem smoothie wird drauf
gestellt aber konsens ist ja in the
french toast
ihr habt noch ein bisschen drachenfrucht
dazu ein grünes musik bei mir auf dem
teller so probiert das ganze erst dann
geht die kamera aus ist ganz in ruhe
auch und dann kommen wir zur bewertung
ist das ist euch gerne schmecken und ich
das jetzt mal so die welt habt ihr also
ich finde das erste gespräche nach
zweite schwere süße sammer überhaupt
schon vorher natürlich bewusst mit das
wird eine süße nummer komplette aber der
suche nach technischen herbert züchter
zu sagen das war lecker erfolglos also
ich kann noch ein paar mal so zügig ich
gewusst dass ich rot violette habe ich
natürlich wenig mehr zu tun gehabt man
ja nicht gekauft die dracula dracula
fenster und ich will ja etwas
übertreiben weil er wird ja immer noch
ich würde erstmal seinen 80 es ist kein
kleines erst zu reden nachts ist und
eingeblendet ist ein sehr solider
starken tag beim mittagessen gehe ich
mal richtig gehen wir mal richtig viel
selbst deshalb sehen uns jetzt da zum
mittagessen machen die wiener schnitzel
mit pommes kaffee sogar ein video
gemacht wie man die besten fans der welt
macht und genau die werde ich jetzt zu
bereiten
ich muss anfangen in dem ich erst mal
jede menge kartoffeln chips kommt und
die pommes schneiden wir jetzt in so ein
halber einheit zentimeter breite stifter
müssen noch nicht super gleichmäßig sein
sondern einfach so ein bisschen das ist
wirklich homemade aussieht so sind die
eigentlich perfekt ecke und seine
familie sind jetzt gerade unterwegs und
ich werde jetzt die kartoffeln weiter
vorbereiten zuallererst kochen wir die
kartoffeln froh in das wasser in dem wir
die kartoffeln kochen fügen wir ein
wenig essig hinzu ich sage euch einfach
trotzdem noch mal kurz das rezept wie
ich das immer mache dann brauche ich
noch salz was hier schon vorbereitet hat
ist meine
der straße die ich gleich brauchen wir
sie wiener schnitzel doppel griffiges
mail semmelbrösel sodann für mich auch
schon die pommes in das kochende wasser
kaymer auf 8 - also die eier einfach
drauf schlagen sich sagt sag zeuge für
die hunde an die stadt habe aber wir
schütten jetzt die kartoffeln ab so die
lassen jetzt ein paar minuten abdampfen
das heißt für mich dass ich schon mal
anfangen kann schnitzel zu klopfen
wirklich freue mich immer wenn ich
diesen hammer benutzen kann irgendwie
keiner special für mich ihn schon schön
klein müssen natürlich trotzdem klopp
werden das ist der größte topf mit dem
ich arbeiten kann dementsprechend werde
ich die schnitzel reagieren müssen so
kann spitze klopfen immer wichtig und
anderer meinung also wie super zart das
fleisch dann könnt ihr auch schon mit
der pannierstraße an können sagt wir
nehmen jetzt hier in schnitze fürchten
dass ein wenig an von beiden seiten
geben was einmal in unser doppelt
richtiges meer kann man ruhig auch so
ein bisschen sitzen lassen müssen
anrücken werden wir das klären wir sehen
dass ihn ein
lasst uns so ein bisschen ansaugen und
dann kommt auch in die semmelbrösel da
kann man schon so ein bisschen bedecken
und dann hat unser spiel auch schon eine
traumhafte panade so ich pausiere ganz
kurz die schnitzel hier muss ich nämlich
weiter um die pommes kümmern was habe
ich mir dafür zwei backbleche benutzen
diesmal backpapier hier auch verteilen
wir jetzt diese kartoffeln wie sie jetzt
eigentlich abgedampft durch den essig
ceo elastisch gehen und vom programm
reaktions und darüber geben wir jetzt
ordentlich geld muss will muss wirklich
jede menge sein wird am ende sowieso weg
gefehlt hat also es ist nicht so als
würde man da jetzt irgendwie übertreiben
an mengen wer das ganze schön durch das
du dich schon allen seiten benetzte
backofen es auch 230 grad vorgeheizt
dann geben wir auch schon nein
jetzt haben wir das ganze erst mal 15
minuten lang an backen während er es mag
hier weiter stützen fertig aber das
müsste ja nicht sehen wir sehen uns
gleich weiter nach über die erste zeit
herum
ich habe dieses gute werk zeug hier
gefunden das werde ich machen warum
kommst zutritt
jetzt lassen wir sie einfach so lange
drin dass die knusprig sind wir sind
jetzt alle vorbereitet und dann legen
wir das erste schnitzel rhyner
nur hier ihre jason das spät wie du es
dir gewünscht hast einen haarschnitt
sind mit selbstgemachten pommes preis
wären natürlich ganz wichtig und ein
bisschen zitronen
das hat echt richtig original lassen uns
gerne probieren ich bin sehr gespannt
wie es schmeckt ich habe der jet mit
dadurch dass schon langsam ganz den
ersten eindruck sagen aber auch keinen
also es geht auf jeden fall um die
richtigen menschen nicht bedacht ist das
zuhause so sehr wie kriege so original
wie mehr sagen denn ich gesehen dass
gleichzeitig auch der letzte baum ist
wurde noch gegessen gerade heuer
praktisch muss ja echt ein kompliment
machen dass sie nicht mehr so also das
würde ich auch möglicherweise so sagen
weil sie so lange spiesse gezielt
vorbereitet ist es nicht es hat einfach
nur geld ist häufig sehr ich habe mir
natürlich größte mühe gegeben ich finde
das immer cool geworden weil sowas
kriegst du alles von anfang an selbst
macht sind es ist unglaublich dass man
quasi diese original wiener schnitzel
sein zuhause hat ohne irgendwelche
restaurant find ich geil das ist nämlich
die wie so dünn sind dass sie sich so
wählen und auch die polnische seite
überrascht genau perfekte mann von außen
trotzdem drin so schön wie kartoffelbrei
ja jeder sein muss unglaublich also
pröbstinger dreckmann nein ich gebe dir
die neuen e10 gebe ich dir nicht weil
irgendwann muss man mal wieder was
anderes essen
es gibt jetzt sehr gut danke wir bauen
ich würde sagen wir springen ich zum
abendessen sondern zum bisher das habe
ich nämlich gerade eben schon
vorbereitet und ihr seht jetzt wieso hat
ihr seht dass jetzt gerade nach dem
mittagessen ich mache es aber schon vor
dem mittagessen ist wird nämlich die
nachspeise die es heute unser dritter
gang die ganze family ist nämlich nur
zweimal am tag und deshalb machen wir
auch zwei große mahlzeiten so brunch und
wir machen leveln bars die kennt ihr
vielleicht tommy hat ihr letztes für
mich gemacht und ich finde es ist mit
das leckerste was man essen kann
wir legen jetzt muss ich werde dafür zum
ersten mal im thermomix benutzen
für die soundeffekte ist übrigens ihr
leiter verantwortlich das spiel knapp
mit transformers willst du mal hallo
sagen wir machen zuerst den teig von den
leveln bars dann wollen wir 250 gramm
weizenmehl 60 gramm puderzucker und eine
packung butter sie sind nicht sehr
gesund so viel kann man dazu sagen wir
geben die butter rhein zeigt alles was
hier machen könnt ihr natürlich auch mit
den händen einfach machen oder mit einer
normalen küchenmaschine mit höherer
funktion also lasst euch nicht davon
abschrecken
mach mir mal die waage auf und jetzt
geben wir 250 gramm mehl das rund 60
gramm puderzucker parallel heizen wir
den ofen auf 175 grad ober unterhitze
vor so der tages fertig geknetet und der
backofen fast vorbei das heißt wir
brauchen jetzt eine backform ihr habt
mich selten in meinen videos backen
sehen bisher ich habe einfach noch nicht
gebacken in meinem leben geht über zeit
für ein erstes mal und das habe ich mir
das hier gut und die verkehrt sondern
sparen wir jetzt fragt papier hier drin
eintopf das sieht sehr gut aus jetzt
wollen wir unseren teil hier raus wenn
denn hier ein bisschen schwer raus zu
bekommen war das kriege ich hin zu
werden also leute die sich krass
auskennen mit thermomix wie gesagt mein
erstes mal hier und jetzt drücke ich das
ganze möglichst glatt an streift das
aber jetzt in dem fall ein bisschen ich
würde sagen dass es so weit gut aussehen
geben wir jetzt zum backen im ofen da
muss ich jetzt möglichst viel saft raus
bekommen ihr kennt den trick vielleicht
man reibt die so ein bisschen über den
tisch dadurch würde das innen drin schon
schön sagt man merkt auch wie die direkt
weich werden und sich das pro fleisch
löst wo wir die aber gleich auf machen
greifen wir noch ein wenig an der
testabteilung ich habe nie gelernt wenn
es weiß wird nicht weiter sonst wird's
bitter ich hoffe ich kriege das so gut
wie sturm ehrliches lied es habe auch
schon wieder bock drauf wenn es zu in
zeiten wo ich das video hier drehen
lange her ist dass ich das für von sturm
gekocht bekommen habe so sehr gut
jetzt kann nicht so super viel wie ihr
sehen könnt jetzt probieren wir 100 120
milliliter saft raus zu bekommen in die
hand reichen pressen so werden die kerne
direkt in der hand liegen 120 milliliter
zitronensäure darunter gebe auch schon
wieder zum thermomix da gehen jetzt
unseren saft hinein vier esslöffel mehl
dann vier eier dazu und 300 gramm zucker
außerdem noch ein klein wenig rum aroma
aus damit es wieder zeit das ganze zu
vermissen so unser tag vorgebacken
machen wir auch raus und die schütten
wir jetzt einfach hier oben vorsichtig
drauf so und jetzt wird das drauf ist
vorsichtig alles wieder in den backofen
und für weitere 20 minuten backen
so wir wollen jetzt mal den kuchen raus
und den lassen wir jetzt draußen einfach
abkühlen bis wir gleich essen
[Musik]
das große finale eco wollte ist nicht
viel essen wie ich habe mir trotzdem
übel zu viel hat anfang gegeben
den tag über und das entschied das
finale das sind lernen also quasi ein
kleiner kuchen ich geb dir mal auf zwei
stück ja ein bisschen auch auf jeden
fall bedient so viel kann ich sagen
sieht schon sehr vielversprechend muss
ich sie ja ich gebe mein stück hinauf
und dann mittlerweile ist ja ein alter
hase einmal probiert kamera geht
auskennst den spaß natürlich wird das
hier sehr gut auf dem drehteller von
sally verklappt alis familie freundin
und jetzt liebe grüße
da sind natürlich das allerbeste weil
dann weiß man auch dass man sachen zum
backen hat das ist geschafft erst mal du
sollst nicht viel essen du hast trotzdem
sehr viel gegessen ich hoffe du bist
nicht ganz unglücklich darüber dass
alles gut ist dann zurück ich hab eben
über können so prof manchmal gab zudem
bekannt geworden
ich habe ihn überhaupt nicht bemerkt
weil ich bin der meinung das haben wir
jetzt alles sarah festgestellt wenn man
titel macht da muss man sich fast auch
was feines also wo man dann halt auch
mit philip roth und dann im nachhinein
geschenken ist ja dann sofort er nicht
denkbar das habe ich dann gemacht kuren
es extrem viel hass entwickelt exempel
es wird kompliziert die was vergeben
muss aber weiß was ich geb doch mal zu
recht
das ist super gemacht
ich habe ich noch nie gemacht aber ich
habe das nie gesagt das rezept vom
training fand ihr auch super lecker dank
für die zehn punkte danke den tag hier
verbringen durfte wirklich
der cooler tag und ich würde sagen wir
leute sehen uns nächsten sonntag um 14
uhr zur nächsten folge einen tag
persönlicher corp